[Music]
what happens to a person when they fully
give their hearts to christ and truly
repent
yeah what does that person go through
all right let's pray father in heaven
continue to speak through us all of us
give us truth give us light i pray in
jesus name amen
what happens to a person when the person
gives the life entirely to christ the
life of christ begins to be expressed in
that person galatians 2 20. paul says i
am crucified with christ's meaning he
has died to his past life as christ died
and he has risen with christ romans 6
4-6 he has he died with christ he rose
with christ if we are planted in the
likeness of his death we shall be also
in the likeness of his resurrection
romans 6 5 so the person who's given the
life to christ has died with christ and
rises with christ to walk in newness of
life first john 2 6
we should walk even as he walked and so
the person who's given the life to
christ will begin to live the life of
christ if that surrender is truly
complete and it is renewed daily it must
be renewed daily so a surrendered life
becomes
the vehicle to which christ expresses
his life
to that person
i am crucified with christ nevertheless
i live yet not i but christ liveth in me
that's the experience of a person who
has truly given the life to christ and
does that daily
the person loves the things of christ
spiritual things becomes his or her
priority and the person can say like job
i have to steam the words of his mouth
more than my necessary food the person
can stay like jesus himself i have need
to eat you know
the person who said like jeremiah thy
words were found and i did eat them the
person is saying like david or how love
i die it is my meditation all the day
that's the change that comes over that
person spiritual things become the
person's priority
amen amen